當充最挫折的是
不是輸給股市
跟你明明有看指標
有照著做
結果還是賠錢
你根本不知道問題出在哪裡
今天我要告訴你一件事情
你用的那個指標
大部分人都只看到他的一半
另外一半才是真正告訴你
什麼時候進場的訊號
今後把它說清楚
這招就叫做
MACD臨走情非當充數
大家好 我是摩卡
當充實戰十年了
教學五年
很多新手告訴我
他們看到指標上的柱子
由綠變紅
就覺得要買
結果每次都買在最高點
一進去就往下跌
問題不是指標沒用
是你看的地方不對
今天我來告訴你
真正有用的訊號藏在哪裡
影片最後我會給你分懶人包
臨走起飛當充數的完整操作步驟
只可以成一張圖
讓你截圖帶走
看到後面記得收藏起來
在講怎麼操作之前
先把MCD是什麼給說清楚
MCD是看盤軟體裡面內建的分析工具
全名叫做
指數平滑一通移動平均線
聽起來很複雜
但你不需要記這個名字
你只需要知道它長什麼樣子
你打開看板軟體
在股票走速度的下方
有一個獨立的區域
裡面有兩條線在交叉移動
旁邊還有一排紅色和綠色的柱子
在上下調動
兩條線一條叫做快線
反應比較快
股價移動它馬上跟著變
一條叫做慢線
做的比較穩
代表大方向
很多新手看到紅柱子變長
做充電去買
但等你看到柱子最長的時候
不一樣往往拍到小腿的
這個時候進去很容易買在高點
今天這套方法完全不看柱子
只看兩條線的一個關鍵位置
我現在就告訴你那個位置在哪裡
在MACD的畫面裡
你會看到一條線穿過中間
把兩個區域分成上下兩半
這條橫線的數值是0
在股票階的數與叫做0軸
今天我們就把它叫做地平線比較好記
這條地平線代表今天整體買賣力量的分界點
兩條線在下面表示賣出力量可能較強
兩條線在上面表示買進力量可能較強
你可以想像一架飛機在跑道上加速
輪子還沒有離地之前需要一段時間累積速度看起來沒什麼
但力量一直在積累
等到速度夠了
輪子離地的那一刻才是真正要起飛的瞬間
MACD的兩條線在低頻線下方靠近的時候
就像飛機還在跑道上蓄力
最關鍵的時刻是兩條線
同時從低頻線下方往上傳越的那一個瞬間
表示買進的力量剛剛超過了賣出的力量
不怕有機會從平靜
突然進入加速到往上走的一個狀態
這個瞬間就是我們要等的訊號
好 開始說具體怎麼操作
第一步設定時間週期
把走勢儲切換到一分鐘K棒的模式
也就是
每一根柱子代表一分鐘的股價變化
這個設定讓你的畫面更新速度夠快
能抓到當天盤中的一個即時變化
第二步
找到符合條件的股票
你要找的是兩條線
目前都在地平線下方
而且非常接近地平線
用一個比喻說明
就像一個人蹲在地上準備要起跳
他蹲得越低
離地面越近
跳起來的瞬間越容易看得到
你要找的股票就是那種
兩條線已經蹲好之勢
準備隨時往上衝的一個狀態
同時就在時間股票的走勢
是在一個小範圍內來來回回
沒有明顯的大漲或大跌
這種狀態代表擺賣雙方的力量
正在接近平衡
一旦有一方突破
就容易出現一波快速移動
什麼時候開始找
早上開盤前10分鐘
股價上下震盪劇烈
可以等9點10分
股市稍微穩定之後再開始觀察
第三步來了
這也是最多新手高錯的一步
你要看清楚
你盯著MACD的畫面
等待一個具體的畫面出現
快線和慢線
從地平線下方往上穿越
來到地平線上方
注意是兩條線都要過
不是只有快線過去
慢線還留在下面
很多人就是在這裡
少確認了一個步驟
只看到快線衝上去
以為訊號成立就馬上買進
結果慢線還沒跟上
甚至根本沒有穿越
整個訊號就有可能是假的
買進去之後,股價馬上往下跌
兩條線都站上地平線
代表這是買賣雙方的力量對比轉變
是比較確定的
不是短暫的假動作
等到那一分鐘的時間到了
這根柱子定型了
你確認兩條線都在地平線上方
這就是這套方法的進場時機點
這個進場點是整個方法的核心
你本的是買賣雙方力量
剛剛翻轉的那一刻
進場的時機也是最糟的
承擔的風險也相對比較小
買進去之後會出現兩種結果
結果一股票繼續往上走
繼續放著跟著走
等股價漲到你覺得滿意的一個位置再賣出
直到方法起飛成功之後
股價有機會往上繼續走一段
你可以根據當下的走勢來決定出場的時機
結果二兩條線又跌回地平線下方
代表這次訊號失敗了
立刻賣出接受小損失
不要等不要猶豫
你可能會想再等一下說明它又會漲回來
這個念頭是這套方法最危險的第一人
因為你經常的理由是
兩條線站上地平線
現在他們跌回去了
經常的理由消失了
繼續等你就只是在讀
跟這套方法的邏輯就完全相反
規則很清楚
快線重新跌回地平線下方就出場
這套方法
失敗的損失通常很小
但只要起飛成功
後面往往有機會
賺到比損失更多的獲利
好 進出場的規則說完了
但這裡要誠實告訴你一件事情
MCD有兩件事你一定要知道
第一個提醒
MCD有可能是落後指標
它是根據股價過去一段的時間變化計算出來的
等到訊號出現
股價可能已經先動了一些
你進場的位置不一定是最好的起點
第二個提醒
MCD可能會有假突破
兩條線穿越了地平線
但背後沒有真實的買進力量支撐
股價很快就掉下來
光看MCD也許沒辦法分辨真假
所以這套方法最好當作
初步判斷的工具
正在下單之前
還需要搭配我一直在強調的三個方法
這也是我的學員每一次進場前
一定要確認的
第一個看五檔掛單
買賣雙方排隊等候的一個清單
確認買方有沒有大單支撐
守住股價
是不是真的掛單
第二個看成交名系
每一筆真正完成的買賣及時記錄
確認有沒有連續買進的一個動作
代表真的有資金積極進場
第三個看市場大方向
今天整個台灣股市的一個整體走勢
大盤往下跌的時候
各股逆市往上走
難度會比較高
序號可靠度也會降低
MACD零軸起飛當重速
告訴你有機會起飛
這13個確認
再告訴你是不是真的
兩個加在一起
就是一個完整的競場判斷
今天這套零軸起飛數
你現在就能帶走實用
但實際操作的時候
很多人遇到一個困難
兩條線穿越地平線了
你買進去
結果補價
不漲反跌
這就是所謂的
假突破
假突破之所以會騙到人
是因為光看兩條線
有沒有穿越地平線
有時候還不夠
背後還有一些訊號
可以幫你判斷
這次穿越的是真的還是假的
什麼時候要進去
生率比較高
什麼時候要等一等
這個判斷的方法
我在一場免費的
線上直播講座裡
有完整分享
包括要怎麼看懂
一檔股票到底會不會漲
為什麼會漲
這些背後的秘密
幫助你在進場前
多了一層
確認大幅提升
每次進場的生率
完全零元
但每周明而有限
下方資訊欄有連結
選一個你能參加的嘗試
報名就好
好 對線開頭說的承諾
畫面上這張圖
截圖存起來
明天開盤前對照一下
記住一個核心
兩條線都過了
才值得嘗試買進
任何一條疊回去就走
今天學完之後
給你一個明天的任務
打開開盤軟體
找集檔今天買賣比較熱絡的股票
切換到一分鐘可以把
MACD打開
然後問自己一個問題
這兩條線
現在在地平線的上面還是下面
有沒有靠近地平線
準備穿越的一個現象
就這樣
先練習每天問自己這個問題
讓眼睛習慣這個畫面
能讓你覺得自己能穩定找到那個穿越的瞬間
再考慮實際操作
如果這部影片讓你有說過
歡迎分享給身邊也在學當中的朋友
我是摩卡
我們下部影片見